just to follow up on what we were
talking about you know there's two
schools of thought you have people that
say you can't be so precious about the
work you can't hold it so tightly and be
so paranoid and then you have someone
like a Steve Jobs who's incredibly
secretive you wouldn't know sometimes
what was coming out or there were you
know rumors amidst Apple whatever and we
wouldn't know until years later
sometimes of things which obviously
worked out for him in many ways so it's
an interesting mix how do we kind of go
in the middle where we're not too
paranoid too precious I mean I see
sometimes filmmakers won't even have
their their trailer embeddable they
won't even make it so people can embed
them on it on a someone else's website
because they're they're afraid or
whatever maybe they just didn't click
the button but to that level versus
someone that's an open book that is
unfortunately easily taken advantage of
and I'm not saying that happen in your
case but I mean believing in the good of
people because they're good you know I
think there's there's a fine line yeah I
mean I look there's two sides to every
idea and and and one is knowing the time
in the place so for example a lot of
filmmakers hold their cards so close to
their vest or their shafts that it's
self-defeating classic example most
studio executives in the marketing
department will tell you that they are
considered Satan by filmmakers
filmmakers will not share one iota about
their film one frame of their film until
it's absolutely locked and loaded which
means that the marketing department has
precious little time to really think
about and be creative and come up with
great concepts and execute on those it's
a last minute 11th hour deal and it
almost always is right is that in the
filmmakers best interest
I suspect not I know that when many many
years ago I did a picture at Universal
young writer-director his first
Direction gig and together we went in
with storyboards and we and I and I
insisted that we have someone from every
department present or two people from
every department every show up we had
like 16 or 18 people in the room
representing every conceivable area of
marketing and we presented to them and
said look we just came to say hi we want
to know what you do and we want you to
be aware of our little project because
it's not the biggest on your lot and so
if you would we just want to share with
you a little bit about in Genesis the
history of the project we want to share
some storyboards by the way the
storyboards suck and you guys are so
much smarter but it was just something
away we could communicate to you but
most importantly before we leave after
we've shut up and we've had some Q&A
what we really want from you is we want
your guidance telling us while we're out
on location shooting what do we need to
bring back what do you need to do your
job better
what kind of still images what kind of
b-roll you what do we need to bring to
you so that you can be the best they
literally said to us we're veterans
we've been here 15 years 20 years 25
years 30 years whatever we've never ever
had filmmakers conduct this kind of a
meeting that was at Universal Pictures
Wow
okay so there there's there is there is
clearly this sort of tradition in in the
human race to hold very very dear to
keep very private are what we consider
our IP our baby and I think sometimes
it's service and sometimes it's
self-defeating
it's you know but I I think you just
have to sort of be sober about it and
and you know look at what other
successful people do and how they do it
and the flip side of that is I never
worry that much about people stealing
what I have I have this crazy idea that
each of us is so gifted and special in
the way that we would do something that
no one can steal any of my ideas and and
do it the way I would do it let them let
them do their version of it No so I can
write a book or I can produce a movie or
I can I can nurture a recording artist
or whatever those things are an idea is
worth very very little in Hollywood it's
the people and and and their ability to
deliver on an idea and birth out of
nothing that's what we do we birth added
thin air something very concrete very
compelling hopefully that moves people
happily or sadly I think it's the doer
not the idea so I think theft is
actually an interesting concept in a
world of IT and I don't really take out
an insurance policy I don't worry about
it I don't think about it
you